in this tiny makeshift kitchen on the
outskirts of lima women put together
whatever they can to create a nutritious
meal on the menu recently was rice
carrots corn and chicken bones cut up in
tiny pieces so everyone can get some
protein says reina franco
we only eat lunch there is no budget for
breakfast and in the evenings each one
has to figure out what to put on their
tables communal kitchens around the
country were her response to the
pandemic that left 4 million
impoverished people without jobs more
than 250 000 feet on meals that cost
less than 30 cents
rising fuel prices have made some
ingredients like meat or chicken
impossible to buy and local government's
donations to keep them going are waning
in some areas government distribution of
basic ingredients stopped more than four
months ago
the local government does not remember
us at the top of the hill they offer
help during political campaigns but then
they forget about us
some of these communal kitchens feed 20
to 30 people every day others two to
three hundred many say this is the last
resort to feed their families and they
say if they didn't have this they
wouldn't know where to turn to for help
to alleviate the pressure the government
has suspended some taxes on fuel and
some basic products but analysts say
that's insufficient
no doubt there is hunger and it's going
to get worse inflation is here to stay
for a long time reducing the purchasing
power of households particularly of the
poorest the government apparently
believes that prices can be controlled
but this is not possible
the finance ministry already estimates
this year investment growth will be zero
community leader edith accurio blames
president pedro castillo
the president's priority is not the
vulnerable families i feel angry because
he should be concerned about the people
in need
leaders of the near 3000 kitchens around
the country say they are desperate the
women have postponed a nationwide
protest waiting for the government to
resolve the food crisis but they say
their children are hungry and time is
running out mariana sanchez lima peru